[MUSIC]
Psychedelics are super illegal.
Even with all the recent media buzz and
MDMA, known as molly or ecstasy,
and psilocybin,
the active ingredient in magic mushrooms.
Are schedule one drugs,
which by definition,
means they are highly addictive and
have no medical value.
Now, if you could all kindly
look under your seats,
what you'll find is just a pinch, okay no.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not today,
today I talk about a mental
health problem that is just so
big, it's hard to wrap our
heads around 8 million
people in the US have
Post Traumatic Stress Disorder.
15 million suffer from alcoholism,
300 million people
globally face depression.
300 million people is all
the people in Canada times 8.
Eight Canada's in every single
person is sick and hurting.
Can't sleep at night,
can't hold a job have lost their autonomy,
their ability to connect with people,
they're contemplating suicide.
They have tried again and
again to heal and
have failed and it's not their fault.
What we have available for treatment
today is just not getting the job done.
Therapy alone has
definitely helped some but
dropout rates are high and
most people maintain their diagnosis.
Antidepressants come with
a whole host of trade offs.
Here, take these pills, they'll manage
your symptoms might make you feel
weird in other ways and take them
from now until forever, give or take.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, back to psychedelics,
one of the most promising mental
health treatments in the last 30
years is psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy.
Using psychedelic substances
alongside therapy to treat
some of our most debilitating conditions,
depression,
anxiety, PTSD, addiction among others.
But how could that be?
It is fair that some of you might be
picking your jaws up off the floor.
Others might know the potential of these
substances from personal experience and
others here I know are experts who you
yourselves could give your own compelling
talks on the safety and efficacy research
of psychedelic assisted psychotherapy.
With that in mind,
here's what I'll share as one of the 300
million who has suffered from depression.
MDMA and psilocybin are safe.
An important note here is that
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
is delivered in a controlled
supervised safe setting.
With preparatory sessions before
reflection sessions after and
during the drug assisted experience,
picture eyeshades,
headphones and classical music.
You're tucked in under a blanket
with a therapist on your right and
a therapist on your left.
That sounds pretty great
without any psychedelics.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And again,
we do see some progress
with therapy alone.
But when you add psychedelics,
the impact goes to a whole nother level.
You start seeing data for
first responders with
severe PTSD who have
failed prior treatment and
after receiving MDMA
assisted psychotherapy,
over 50% no longer have PTST.
12 moths later that number continue
to rise without additional
intervention to two thirds of
patients no longer having PTST.
There are similarly remarkable data for
suicide in administered in
conjunction with psychotherapy,
substantially reducing depression and
anxiety in patients with
with terminal cancer.
Again with persisting sustained effects.
Now the commonality across
the conditions being explored is
that they are diseases of rigidity.
Where destructive thoughts of others
of ourselves have overtime, calcified.
The negative feedback loop
digging us deeper and
deeper into the grooves of our own psyche.
We're stuck.
MDMA is thought to help
PTSD in a couple ways.
First, it's an empathigen.
It fosters empathy and connection.
This pro social quality is thought to
enhance the rapport between therapists and
patient rapidly accelerating
the healing process.
Second, in the brain on MDMA,
we see a quieting of our fear center and
an uptick in our memory and
critical thinking what's one theory
is that this fear extinction and
memory re-consolidation allows us to
face memories of traumatic events
without the fear impulse that typically
comes up and shuts things down.
Instead, we can process these memories
with emotions other than fear.
Maybe this trauma isn't my fault.
The tone of those memories
start to take on a different
color when it isn't so
brutal or so haunting.
The depression, anxiety and
addiction we are stuck in negative
luminations I am worthless.
Nothing matters.
Alcohol controls my life.
And what psilocybin and
other classic psychedelics seem
to do is help us break
out of that narrative,
to shake things up and
to see the world in a new way.
The patient anecdotes
are truly astounding.
Themes of transformation and awakening,
themes of deep connection and
unity to everything, to nature,
to total strangers,
realizing we are all in this together.
Now, think of another experience
described as transformational.
Life changing, where we get to learn so
much about ourselves,
connect deeply with others and
see the world in a new way.
Places like Stanford,
change lives and change the world.
And that is exactly the kind of
firepower we need behind this movement.
Researchers have worked tirelessly for
decades for
this first opening,
to get these drugs off schedule one and
legally provide psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy.
The first FDA approval
could come as soon as 2022.
That is not a lot of time to build out
a world that supports this treatment.
University, psychedelic research
centers and medical programs inclusive
of psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
you need to happen right now.
This treatment has enormous potential,
but its impact will be limited.
If we don't figure out a few things.
First, therapist training.
Anyone who has tried to find a therapist
lately knows it can be daunting.
I thought recruiting was just for
summer internships.
I did not know that to find a therapist,
I would also need to reach into the depths
of my Rolodex, ask for referrals,
all in hopes of finding the right culture
fit just to be turned way repeatedly.
There simply aren't enough.
Universities have the infrastructure
to scale this much needed skill set.
The campus, the educators and
most importantly the vibrant
commitment to world class
cutting edge treatment.
Second, diversity championing is
a good thing that universities
care deeply about creating
inclusive environments,
because they have huge sway in terms
of shaping our future leaders.
Who gets educated?
Who gets a shot?
Who gets the platform?
Universities can bring together
communities of researchers,
students, patients who mirror
the makeup of all those
impacted by the conditions
this treatment can heal.
A critical step towards
equitable treatment access.
And lastly, reducing stigma.
The Imperial College of London and
Johns Hopkins University have
already established
psychedelic research centers.
What if Stanford also had
a psychedelic research center,
Harvard, UCSF think about what that
would do to shape public outlook,
to open people up to the possibility
of another treatment option.
We have made good progress,
moving past the stigma of talking
about mental health problems.
Now it's time to start overcoming
the stigma of talking about
mental health solutions.
You or someone you know and love,
struggles with mental
health which means you
have a role to play as a donor,
an innovator,
an advocate, there is room for everyone.
We are in this together.
So let's get a lot of
healing to a lot of people.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]